.
N
VICTORY.
R.
>> PROGRTH WASEYRTROLICANS TO G
SOPHOMOREGRSWAS-CONS ON BEING A
GOOD TOUP.
RESSWOMAN, HOW MUC
OWE PROGRESSIVE
MOVEMENT AND LEARS
FO VICTORY?
>>,HIIEVE THAT
PRESIDENT-CE NIGHT HEWOULD THE
PROGRESSIVE AND MAKEIVE B ATIC .
E THE
GRASSROOTS AND WE CELEBRATE THES
I THINK A US.
I THINK WE OWE
COMMUNITIES A I THINK WE OWE CL
COMMUNITIES OF COLO
MMUNITIES A GREAT DEAL IN
SEEING THEM AND HONORING THEM
OUR GIOU COULD TAKE OFF YRCO F
PERSONHAT DTTO YOU AS A WOMAN O
SE BLACKOMAN
PRESIDENT-ELECTED  IEA IT'S REA.
FOR SO MANY O US
WOMEN,ROWN UP MY ENTIRE CHILDHOY
WOULD NEVE  A
BLACK PRESIDENT AND, LU
THAT
BUT NOW A
OF COLOR AND L BLACKWOMAN TO SEG
IN THE RLL REMARKABLENDT BE WHAT
IS SAI IAZING THAT LITTLE  ARE H
ETHO THECALLEDM
BAN.
ASGHREPUBLICANS, AT LEAST
ARY, WILLD
OF THE SENATE.
THAT IS COMPLICATE YOURHE D TOG
E LEGISLATION. Y C YOU W HOUSE
BUT DOESN'T THE SETE GOING TOU
MODERA S REPUBLICANS TO
TRY TETHINGTHE
HOUSE THAT CANHROUGH THE
SENA. >> WELL, I'M SND
MY NEXTONTHS D THAT
HELP AND OER
WORK OF FANIC LDE
STEAROM LIKE SCEY MAKE D AUBLIC
MAJORITY, THAT WE IGIA, THA SECR
A DEMOCRATIC SENATE MAJORITY SO
T  5tLIE,HAT
AROUND THE TIME THA
WILL BENG SWET-ELEC
AND VIESIDENT-ELEC INK IT'S REA
GIVE THE SENATE .
>> A THELECK I'LL ASK
YOU THA AGAIN, OKAY?
>> Y
>> I'LL LET YOU PUNT THAT O
NOW.
HOAKER NANCY PELOS
BIDEN A BUT DEMOC ARE POTENTIA
MAJORITY AND THEORETICALL AREPU
LAYHING THAT  AFE CALL DEMOCRATL
>> I IMAGINEE NT.
WH IHEWR
>>SOYO AND
FOREMOST,AN ACKNOWL
SO MANY -- IACKNOWLEDGE,
RS LONG OUR D
MESIS N T
DEHA LEVIED FFECTIVEATTACKSGAURD
OURSELVES AGAINST TH? LOOK AT S
YOU SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS THAT
M CAMPAIGNED ON
ALDEFUND
LIN ELECTION. LARGELY SLOGANS
WEREDSROUPS THAT WE SAW IN
TH LUPRISINGNY AGAIPO
SO HOW CAN WE A MOREOEPS?
MANY WE CAN POINT IN CENTRALIZN
FOR  OUR DIGITALGNING IS VERY W
REPUBLICANS ARESTYOU  PRESIDENTW
LARGELY ON DIGITAL ORGANIZINGAN.
HA MANYVEIGZI
WHEREAS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY  TW
MORE RESILNT TO TG
REPUBLICANATTACKS.
YOU TOL "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
YOU ALMOSTN' RUN FOR
RE-ELECTION BECAUSE OF TREOUOWUO
DO YOU REALLY T
AS THEEMY?DO YOU THINK JOE BID
TH>> I DON B PRESIDENT SEES MEA
I TH OF THE REASONSHY  A MARKED
BE A 2 AND HOW
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WUNIFY TO
RE THEND GE SAMAG TT VOTE DTRUME
CAUCUS, VERY DEEP DIVISIONS
THHE PARTY AND I BELIEVE
TH N RE
TOGETHERAN NARVE
T.D,HAVE AIT'S GOIO E EVER WORKE
SOLID DATARSD TELLIN E OTHER
DO, IT DPE DIVISION IN
THEAR I
IRRESPONSIE,
IRRESPONSIE GASOLINE
ALREADY  PARTY.
LP
ITOT THAT EVERY
ME CAMPAIG NDITIONIVE
IT SPARTY, THE
PARTIS NOT OU KNOW, LLYNTO EXPL
OF THESE SEATS.
I THINK KATIE PTE
AZ EXAMPLE AICHAEL BIT DEEPE THI
IO-COR
ONONS ON B